let's talk about Wonder Woman Wonder
Woman uh
I didn't like love that part
hello everybody and welcome to another
episode of the after show I'm your host
Nikki Novak and today
man we are gonna have a lot to talk
about we're talking about Shazam Fury of
the Gods of course the follow up to the
2019 movie Shazam and this is a
spoiler-filled conversation so if you
have not seen it uh do yourself a favor
watch it before you watch this episode
but if you like it that way then just
continue on and we're just gonna have a
chat we're going to be talking about
deep diving into the film talking about
all the questions the burning questions
that the film Left Behind we're going to
be talking about that Peter saffron
James Gunn DC where it's going
post-credits scene all that good stuff
so we're gonna Dive Right In look I
might not have as much experience as you
because I'm not super old like you but
I've seen all of the Fast and the
Furious movies Lady it's all about
[Music]
first of all I want to welcome my guest
he is the founder and the editor of nerd
reactor John Wynn welcome
yay I'm one person two-person applause
applause
um
first time on the show first time on the
show yes welcome yeah no I'm excited uh
just to be on just to talk about movies
and first time look at the little sets
the Thor ammonia uh Wreck-It Ralph Dr
Strange I love it thank you for
appreciating our set and I keep meaning
to bring and I have my own paraphernalia
that I get during Awards season I keep
meaning to bring in but yeah so let's
dive in are you ready to talk Fury of
the Gods yes okay so let's start out
with that Rotten Tomato score at 52
percent the audience score is at 88 this
is the kind of stuff that gives us a lot
to talk about and here's the consensus
more in focused and less satisfying than
its predecessor Shazam Fury of the Gods
still retains almost enough of the
source materials silly charm to save the
day John what do you think about this
what do you think about this about the
critics Score first of all do you agree
what are your what are your general
thoughts before we Deep dive on this
film uh yeah after seeing the numbers I
was a bit surprised like
it's it's all over again with the other
superhero movies uh Black Adam
quantumania because I actually enjoyed
those movies and this one
um but to have it like just really below
that I was like wow all right and then
especially after Oscar season with the
movies so I feel like critics are extra
critical now where would you sort of
fall on that scale are you in between
are you do you are you on one side or
the other I would be more on the 80s
side because I would give this movie
like a 7 out of ten okay yeah so that
would be way higher so it'd be fresh 50s
yeah yeah so here's my little theory
that I'm gonna throw out there
um which maybe people have said but
um and this applies to Marvel as well
because people were really hard in
quantumania people did not like the last
Thor movie people seem to have turned on
funny superheroes I enjoyed the last
Thor movie it's like it's silly fun but
then I was like reading afterwards like
oh this movie's like terrible and just
Marvel recently is just not so good why
do you think that why do you think
people are suddenly giving these films
low scores when like audiences seem to
like them and like you and I seem to
like them why do you think their the
scores have drastically lowered
um I think I was talking to a friend
recently and uh he mentioned about
superhero fatigue and but then he's been
watching a lot of the Oscar movies so
that might be like part of it there's so
many different elements background stuff
that can shape how you view things so I
think the biggest thing would be like
maybe Marvel Superhero fatigue or that
can include DC Superheroes too
um so
that's why uh you know I'm excited for
the future of what James Gunn is going
to do like shake things up we'll see
where it goes yeah we're gonna get into
that too
here's here's what I think I went to see
a public screening of this movie yeah
yeah I am the only person that stayed
for the mid and post-credits scenes
which what does that tell me but you
said there's only four people in there
or yeah but they all just got as soon as
the movie was over they got up they
didn't even occur to them but this
happened to me I'm trying to remember
which
another superhero movie I just saw in
the theater with the public same thing
happened yeah and it made me realize
maybe this is part of what the audience
score is they're just going to have a
good time they're not thinking about the
World building and they're not thinking
about what James Gunn and Peter Safran
are doing yeah they're leaving the movie
and they're thinking did I have a good
time or did I not have a good time and
that's the general public the people
that aren't as invested yeah in where
it's going where it's been as you and I
and the rest of the you know rest of the
critics in the world are yeah um so
let's talk about
what you love like this the things about
the film that worked for you or maybe
favorite scenes oh there's a lot of
scenes oh there is oh my gosh I love
them go for it yeah uh I think uh what's
the first thing that pops up is just
more of the wizard
because in the first movie he has that
moment with uh Billy like talking about
the powers and like you know you must
say my name and then he says the name
and then where's it just disappears he
turns into Ash and that's it and I was
like that's it of the wizard
yeah we thought he was gone you hired
juman uh hansu to play the character and
that's all we get of him but this one
he's back and he gets to have a lot of
just screen time just interacting with
uh more on Freddy's character or the
character Freddy and it's a lot of fun a
lot of jokes a lot of humor I like the
human he was funny in this one which he
wasn't really in the last one there is
it was a choice for sure yeah uh there's
one scene where I was at a
uh one of the characters
uh was like oh unicorns like I love
unicorns and he replies back with well
they don't like you that's see that's
the thing that you've seen it twice and
I completely missed that joke yeah and
I'm I yeah I mean there's a lot there
was a lot of good humor in it I I mean
personally Helen Mirren which I think
it's hilarious that she said that she
didn't I think she said in a press
interview she didn't understand the blot
a lot of the movies or the plot of the
movie
but it didn't matter because she walked
it yeah my favorite moment was yes as
the when she's reading yes yeah she's
reading the stuff that's uh written by
uh Steve the pen which is another one
Steve the pen yeah in the library of
what's it called the library of
something I forgot what it's called um
the library yeah but yeah so the pen is
basically dictating all the kids and
everything they said and yeah for people
who forgot but yeah I think a lot of
people are saying that's kind of their
favorite moment because
I don't know watching it I was just
thinking as an actress it must have been
there it must have been such a
temptation to read it in different
characters voices but she really stuck
to thinking this was all one thought
yeah okay what else did you love uh I
just like Freddy uh just him having his
own story and then getting to meet uh
Anne and
uh the whole turn later on I love that I
wish they fleshed that more out we could
talk about like the the lack of later
but I liked uh just him just his
performance especially at the end with
him and Anne uh fighting against the
dragon uh because the dragon feeds on
their fears and so there's a yeah
there's a moment where they didn't have
superpowers yeah and uh so the only
thing to defeat it is just to have
courage within yourself and
um all the super superpowers didn't
matter and you can see like they're just
really holding on to each other finding
this Dragon you can see it in his eyes
like the fear but he's still trying to
it's uh it's very it yeah Jack uh his
his performance is great I love it it's
very it yes yes very good yeah uh okay
I'm gonna say something that could be
controversial oh
because you brought up Freddy yeah
um in the first one this was very much
and I and I enjoyed the Rachel zegler
you know yeah I liked her performance I
feel like that sort of budding romance
replaced sort of the budding friendship
and Brotherhood between the two and the
first one yeah that was sort of the
sweet story of this one because I feel
like they didn't develop the friendship
between
um Billy Batson and Freddie as much in
this one oh no
um at all actually they kind of both
co-starred him in the film they both had
their own half I felt like but
a lot and a lot of people have been
saying that they didn't feel like
Zachary Levi's energy matched Asher
Angel is it Asher Angel Asher Angels
energy yeah yes because Billy Batson
as Asher as Billy Batson is now 18 19.
yeah and they didn't give him a lot of
the goofy stuff this time they gave him
the more emotional stuff so he was a
little bit more mature and then cut to
Zachary Levi acting like he was 12. yeah
it almost occurred to me and it wouldn't
have worked for the first one that Jack
Dylan Grazer as Freddie Freeman should
have been Billy Batson because he looked
like a younger Zachary Levi to me and
their energy matched like yeah they're
like very like all over the place and
looking around and that would have been
perfect yeah and then I feel like Adam
Brody and Asher Angel's energies matched
I feel like they should have done a
Shazam swap body yeah it seemed like
they were miscast almost in this one and
it was nothing against anybody's
performance it was a choice and I think
had Zachary Levi played an 18 19 year
old I don't know I mean I guess he could
have but yeah
um it's no I I do agree with that with
the young Billy he's very mature and
he's trying to just like whenever he's
interacting with Freddy it's like all
right Freddy can we meet me to the side
uh instead of just causing a scene I was
like oh look at that he's like trying to
take care of him somehow being the older
brother and
uh just some more just calm so I'm like
I don't know I agree with that with uh
and then Zachary Levi when he shows up
it's like hey and if you look at the end
credits you say pew pew pew right
shooting the bottles I'm like ah what a
what a kid and then even uh David
mentioned how he's like oh this guy's
immature and all that yeah yeah yeah and
so but I don't know I think they cast
wrong the first time but it worked in
the first one yeah it really worked but
also Jack Dylan Grazer was a lot younger
and so you really had that
balance between you know somebody much
much much younger and in this one and
you know like from being 18 19 you want
to be 25 you want to be 30. you don't
want to act like a kid anymore at that
age sorry I'm an adult I can do this I'm
gonna drive a car am I there yet 21
drinking age not yet but I'll pretend I
also um speaking of things we liked I
also really liked any sort of
interaction between Helen mirren's
character and Zachary Levi I thought
they had a great dynamic between the two
of them when they were sitting
and they were having all those the only
thing that like wigged me out was when
he was beating matar out of her and you
see Helen mirren's body like flopping
around there's clearly a body devil yeah
but I was like oh ow like can we do that
today mail and Marin like she she uh she
put a dome around everyone and at the
end the third act a lot of people died
like she did redeem herself she did but
then she also killed a lot of people
yeah yeah yeah what do we think of
calypso Lucy Liu
it's just an interesting like her
character I wish there was more of that
family Dynamic of uh what Rachel's
character uh and uh alluded to like oh
my bigger sister yeah uh they're you
know they love it's like they're you can
feel like there's love but then you're
being overbearing I wanted to see more
of that we didn't get to see the family
Dynamics yeah yeah I actually thought
one of the best moments was when Helen
Mirren and they were all sitting on
their Thrones yeah and Helen was reading
the letter and Rachel's reaction to her
where you know when those superheroes
that are trying to be menacing but
they're they're so serious and they're
but and they're hilarious and I thought
Rachel's reactions to her reading the
letter were amazing that Dynamic I
didn't notice that so what happened she
just kind of like
it was comedy but she but it was like
when you don't play the joke you play
the seriousness of the situation like
she was like she was like really
reacting to everything Helen's character
was saying which tells me she did a good
job because she knows when my eyes my
eyes go to a certain actor and it's oh
yeah because I don't think the focus was
supposed to be on her but my eyes were
just drawn to her as as she was reacting
and I just thought it was genius but I
agree about Lucy I think I don't think
it was the actress's fault I just think
it was kind of a material it actually
had the materials that she She Wants
Revenge right and Helen's gonna do
something to make her angry and then uh
betrayal
yeah you're out of here I'm gonna take
over yeah yeah and did you did you
appreciate the flip of Helen's character
of hispira did you think that that
worked for the script
it's it's there I okay for this movie I
just wish there was more of what they're
trying to do I wanted more relationship
between Freddy and Anne so that when
Anne does flip later on because she I
think she flipped too early I want to
feel that I was like oh I'm heartbroken
like I'm watching Freddie he's Head Over
Heels
um so that when the flip does happen uh
I feel like just anguish I guess uh and
then with the with Helen stuff I felt
like that's like an afterthought like
okay all right
um Shazam you did good I guess I'll help
you yeah it wasn't fleshed out yeah
okay so third act it's funny because
again I think I'm opposite to everybody
else because I kept hearing how long and
drawn out the third Act was and I
freaking love the third act yeah I
thought the monsters were so cool I
thought the CG I heard that you know the
dragon let's talk like they used the
same company that does Game of Thrones
because they're like well if we're gonna
have dragons we're gonna go to the
people that yeah so I was for a second I
was like are we watching Game of Thrones
because they looked like Game of Thrones
dragons
um really cool like I thought that
David Sandberg did a really good job in
the first one one of my favorite scenes
in the first one was the office scene
mm-hmm
um if you remember when Mark Strong's
character like comes to the office and
like Chucks the guy out the window
checks his brother out oh yeah yeah and
then you see these monsters for the
first time and they did a really good
job of look if this is a sequel go big
or go home they went so much bigger and
most of the time I find third acts very
tedious when I see one punch and punch
yeah and I did around 40 minutes before
the end
where they sort of regroup and then you
know they're building up to this epic
battle I'm like oh here we go here we go
again
I thought it was great yeah for a change
I loved the third act and I thought it
worked what did you think I thought it
was okay okay yeah I just no I enjoyed
it but it wasn't like I wanted like I
said before the more of the uh
relationship I want to see more of that
like just what happens to the family
after the events of the first one they
just got their powers I want to see them
struggle with that we we see a little
bit of it uh especially with uh Mary's
character where she's not going to
college she's just sticking around with
the family so I want to see her yeah
going to hang out with people her age
because they they've shown the aftermath
with her wearing the shades and she's
like out of it but I want to see that
her like maybe partying with her friends
and then her friends are like come on
let's do this it's like ah no I gotta
hang out with my family we gotta do
something protect people I guess more of
that and then the Third act I felt like
it took away from all that other stuff
definitely did was a different type of a
film yeah but I still enjoyed it for
what it was because it's a superhero
movie you gotta have the uh the stakes
of of the daughters of Atlas taking over
and uh
um Philadelphia just being inside a dome
I think for me at one point I realized
the story wasn't as strong obviously as
the first one but that didn't I was like
that's okay I'm just gonna be
entertained
um and then I started thinking of
potential plots oh yeah I was thinking
what would have been really cool to
explore would be like I wrote down you
know had the goddesses
come there to lure him because they can
use him in their world and how much
power he has oh to maybe fight somebody
else so they lure him in he gets pulled
away from his family where it's like the
story is but we were a core and now
you're you've lost your way because now
you're you're too worried about
conquering different universes and and
almost like he gets a little bit too big
for his own Temptation the Temptation
there you go
the Apple yeah oh God that Apple changed
hands so many times I was like who has
the darn Apple now and by the way what
was with the scene where they capture
um
they capture Lucy's character and then
they just leave her alone in the lair
they just leave her alone in there to go
get the apple and Escape oh yeah no is
it Helens right Helen's character sorry
yeah so she left her alone they just
thought the thing would hold her but I
guess that's them being teenagers and
just going to hang out on the sofa yeah
not even think yeah who knows you know
Helen Mirren would be able to zap melt
or Escape I would have you would have
yeah because you knew beforehand now
this is Helen Mirren yeah yeah you kind
of were all right but then again but in
the movie you know they're like the
daughters of Atlas right so you
just watch them yeah keep five of us
have somebody keep their eyeballs on
them
um and what about the rest of the cast I
didn't think it was necessary Mary maybe
to have Mary play both characters this
time because I think it kind of threw me
off a little bit where they had her do
the older and the younger yeah so I
think it's because she's already like uh
an adult now yeah I feel like it's the
same
um
I think it just threw me off everybody
else so it felt like she got more screen
time yeah without being justified in the
sense because they didn't flesh out the
other family stories as much as they
could have yeah there's so much
potential so much that
um
it makes me sad because I like the
characters I love them every time
they're on the screen the Foster family
yeah the parents and the the kids uh
they're great and I just want to see
more of their struggles especially with
the whole thing with shazam's like I
want to bring us together and everyone
doing their own thing I want to see more
of that I want to see like let's say
Eugene uh Darla
um and the other characters Pedro doing
her own thing and fleshing that a bit
more so that when things happen again
you're like yes this is cool yeah and
that's what they did in the first one
like I said with the hour markers like
it took its time and I think that's a
thing of with sequels when they go
bigger with you know they have a bigger
budget bigger special effects which
actually for the budget I think was 100
million it looked more expensive which I
thought it looked
um but I still feel like they can do
that like each character can have their
moment even if it's a bigger budget like
I have to go back to like Avengers end
game and Spider-Man no way home but then
uh yeah they've been established the
characters before but I still get like
their little moment of just yeah time to
shine and I just somehow maybe work on
the script more so that each character
gets that I just
balance it out somehow yeah yeah I agree
I agree I think the script generally the
story like I said but it didn't take
away from
somehow it didn't take away from my
enjoyment of it yeah no no I still
enjoyed it too
um anything else that stood out that you
love love uh let's see
um let's talk about Wonder Woman Wonder
Woman uh
I didn't like love that part I was like
At first I did and then I thought about
it I was like
mix I'm mixed on it like I like it
because of the gag I love the running
gag with the not showing the head not
showing the head because in the first
one you see Superman not showing the
head so then you see it again it's like
oh here we go again you're not seeing
the head so you're not sure if it's
going to be gal as Wonder Woman and then
later on when you do show her at the end
it's like oh finally they showed it so
that got me excited but then
deus ex machina
like I'm a guy I'll bring back Shazam so
I'm like oh there goes all the uh the
the weight of them losing someone they
care about and it's gone in a moment but
you already know that he's gonna come
back so I actually didn't you didn't
know moment okay at that moment I
thought maybe did we have a reshoot
because DC's resetting yeah did we
decide to make Shazam really sad in the
end or maybe I didn't expect it to come
around in this movie I thought maybe
they're gonna leave it there yeah I
think for this one because shazam's kind
of like a family type movie I didn't
think you were gonna do it you didn't
yeah he's like they can like kids are
gonna be watching this right they can't
kill Shazam yeah I thought wow they went
really dark with this yeah
um
you know again I mean it was spoiled
ahead of time that she was in the movie
um the thing that I have an issue with
is when I can tell it's a body double
because I know Wonder Woman I'm I'm
being a female like I'm just being
honest like I have analyzed gal gadot's
body oh wow and I know her shape and I
was like I knew it wasn't her I'm
talking about the like I know the second
the end credit yes that's her yes but I
still don't think that was her body the
the final reveal yes like it searches
her face no when she's face onto camera
but there's a shot where she's walking
away and I'm like
I think it was a different body double
from the body double and if I insulting
the actress that played that role
because she actually came out on social
media and was like oh I can finally say
that yeah that was me and good for her
yeah she did a great job nothing against
her body or anybody's body everybody has
a gorgeous body but I could just tell
like there's a different person yeah
yeah yeah yeah so I just I but look I
mean anytime she shows up it's exciting
to me because she's one of my favorite
characters I guess it's just kind of
like well we don't know if we're gonna
see her again yeah it's a big tease it's
like what's happening because Black Adam
you teased Superman yeah like is he
gonna uh Black Adam versus Superman are
we gonna get that and then the whole
thing James Gunn uh Henry Cavill had a
meeting and he's like I'm not going to
return and you're like well there goes
that and then this movie comes out
Wonder Woman so
is she gonna come back and no one knows
and I don't know if James God knows yeah
or if he knows he's not telling us
because you know it's now quote unquote
a soft reboot and they they were asked
on the carpet for this if you know if
Suzanne's coming back again and he said
it depends on the box office which
obviously it wasn't great opening
weekend but we don't know what's going
to happen in the future yeah I think the
thing that works in terms of like
post-credit scenes is that it really has
to tease something that's imminent in a
sense or something so big
that no one saw coming even if it's far
in the future that people or there's a
reveal and people go oh my God but
knowing what we know yeah
where does that thing lead where she
obviously comes in and saves him but at
the same time then she just sort of
walks off and it's a very flippant thing
if there had been you know I think maybe
if Black Adam had done really well and
we knew
Black Adam was coming back even like
let's talk about the first post-credits
scene yeah and that he's asked to join
the Justice Society yeah
that one confused me more too because
like okay Wonder Woman it's kind of like
uh this could be like a standalone where
just because it's fans excited like yeah
she's back but then that one uh with the
uh the uh the crew the um Amanda Waller
crew so you're like yeah that's part of
James Gunn so right he's now running
things so now I'm confused on what
they're gonna take or just leave but
then continue on in the future
um
Shazam Society what's going on yeah the
first post-credits scene really didn't
work for me because
I don't want to be mean but when those
two showed up
I don't care about them I really don't
you didn't like them in Peacemaker or uh
big enough to like really care like and
I know it's his wife and she does a fine
job yeah but just given the fact that
like he's running the studio he's
directing Superman Legacy he's also
writing Superman Legacy his wife is
starring at it and like you're getting
rid of Wonder Woman but you're not
getting rid of that like his crew his
peeps right yeah and like Zachary Levi's
buddies with Peter and you know they go
skiing together so I'm like you might be
fine yeah you know it just feels it all
feels very personal yeah so it's not
like a true reboot but it's like if it's
your friends or someone you care about
you're you're safe yeah I just think I
just I just know from past post-credit
scenes when someone shows up or a new
character shows up and you're like oh my
God they're entering the universe yeah
this is amazing this person like what's
his name from Ted lasso that showed up
in you know marvel and oh yeah yeah it's
like it's Hercules yes what even if it's
like wait who him yeah but it's like
after Ted lasso so big so when you see
him like oh there's a reaction this
makes sense or people that don't know
but they're sitting next to someone that
does know it's like what's going on
yeah am I out of the loop here so that I
mean I guess that I just wasn't that
excited about those characters and then
his reaction like thinking he was being
recruited to the Justice League and then
it was like the B Team the Justice
Society I kind of had the same reaction
like again like let's say let's say
because I know too much you know we know
too much behind the scenes so let's say
they Black Adam was massive right and he
was being recruited to Justice Society I
think I'd be more excited oh yeah
because then you'd be like oh he's
joining Justice Society and then
eventually him and Black Adam are going
to have that fight that epic fight that
everybody's talked about for so long
that would have built towards us like oh
I see trouble because he kind of aligned
with Justice Society and Black Adam and
then what if Zachary Levi's character
does Shazam does and then they Clash oh
yeah that would have been exciting oh
yeah that would have been exciting yeah
I think for me just watching that it's
like it's cute but I I can see like with
the end credits you want something like
yes I'm gonna go back I'm excited for
the future uh this one is just oh not
not league but Society oh not the like
let's say Amanda Wall if she showed up
that would have been something but then
they have uh the the other crew the B
team I guess yeah yeah and his reaction
was kind of my reaction like if he had
she said we're recruiting you to the
Justice League I would have been like oh
yeah you know but obviously that's not
where they're going and they filmed
these yeah apparently long before gun
took over and saffron took over so you
know but no yeah it's like you do want
to show something like wow this is
amazing like
like the first time
the like one of the big first end
credits like the first Iron Man movie uh
Samuel Jackson's coming in as uh Nick
Fury it's like I want to form the
Avengers Initiative yes oh this is going
to be big yeah yeah and look I think
they had already shot it I think James
got a paper saffron we're like let's
just leave it in let's leave in the
Wonder Woman Like it doesn't really
affect our reboot in a sense yeah
um so we might as well and then I think
initially they were the Justice Society
was supposed to be in that scene but
then logistically it didn't work to have
them all in so then it was you know in
short notice they got
nothing against those actors I mean
they're fine you know but I'm still
confused about what's going to go on in
the future well let's talk about the
future
um and then the Mr Mind by the way the
second scene yeah
um same as in the first film so do you
think they should just keep that a
running gag in every future film where
it's just like I'm working on it it's
just going slowly but I'll come back for
you or should it actually lead to
something so they can have or like if
the writers can figure out a way to make
him Mr mine epic sure go for it but I
feel like it's a running gag now because
Mr mine talking worm smart talking worm
it's it's silly when you think about it
but I want to see if they can do this
like a serious oh yeah oh it was the
worm all along I'm there for it yeah I
loved starro I love all that stuff yes
I'm so there for it I think I think they
should run with that I think that should
be Shazam three yeah Mr Mr mine and
Savannah
um
anyway uh okay so let's talk about
[Music]
um
where we're going with this whole world
in DC So based on these post-credit
scenes we've kind of said this but does
does it make it more clear or less clear
to you where they're going with the
story or or is it neither it's uh I feel
like it's just like you're just throw in
a dart on a board like let's see where
this goes let's see where this goes
because there was a plan James Gunn
revealed the plan like these are the
movies that's going to come out uh with
the Superman Legacy and the other stuff
and then right now we still have uh
Shazam and then later on we got the
flash
so is it going to be like a full reboot
or are they are they gonna try to do
like a soft reboot yeah where there's
going to be still some characters
continuing on because with the flash
it's a perfect character to try to
reboot things and yeah he can reset the
universe yeah then we have other movies
coming out afterwards like Blue Beetle
what are you most excited for uh which
one Blue Beetle or uh let's say Blue
Beetle or Aquaman Aquaman to the flash
because I want to see Michael Keaton
back as Batman
it's kicking ass
taking names and
I want to see what other surprises they
have because if they if they've shown
Batman Ben Affleck and Michael Keane in
the trailers imagine what Secrets they
have
um
I don't know like we already saw Wonder
Woman back uh Henry Cavill back at
Superman so what else can they do here
that would excite fans what are they
what do you think
um
listen the second Tom Cruise said that
he loved the movie It's All In
I I
wear that came that they showed him I'm
like are they trying to woo Tom Cruise
or brothers what's happening or is he in
it somehow is he in it hmm oh hot damn
what character would he play they showed
a movie yeah maybe oh my gosh he just
had me have me thinking what if he has
like meow crossover between Top Gun
two different companies Warner Brothers
in Paradise somehow they figured it out
I
I just have her
have so much Buzz about the flash yeah
and then when I saw that trailer I
am going to cinema con just to see the
movie Yes I can't wait to see the Flash
oh yeah and by the way we haven't even
established this I'm a huge DC girl like
I
I I loved I loved Ben Affleck as Batman
I love Emma Snyder lover I love the
Snyder cup yeah I love Galileo as Wonder
Woman I love all these characters
I liked Justice League sorry but I
freaking love DC and I love these
characters I don't apologize for liking
Justice League yeah I loved Justice
League are you kidding me yeah yes four
hours I've ever spent on my couch that's
all freaking awesome I did it all in one
sitting that was it
um
so yeah I'm super stoked for the flash
look I don't think these these credit
scenes really affect either way I think
by the way either neither one affects
phase one of what James Gunn has
announced is happening and that's the
Gods and Monsters so I think whatever
was teased here is going to be put on
hold for three four years anyway we're
not going to see the fruition of any of
that so I think that's why it's not that
it's bad I just had a hard time getting
excited about it if I knew something was
coming down the pipeline and it was
teasing something and giving it a reveal
but we're going in a different direction
and you know
um but it's still shown though still
shown in the movie that audience is
going to be watching and they're going
to be excited and people that don't know
about this whole restructuring they're
gonna be like what happened and then
You're Gonna Be Sad yeah yeah I mean and
who knows like who knows yeah who knows
because
Snyder has an announcement coming out I
don't know if it'll have aired when this
airs but you know there's all kinds of
speculation it could just be a screening
I don't know if it's anything in the
future but you know no one's really sad
I think everybody's sort of jockey and
jockeying for position all of the
current superheroes that haven't been
officially let go we love James yeah
that's my best friend uh so it you know
it remains to be seen what will happen
but I'm there for it by the way Aquaman
was um I think is the greatest superhero
movie of all time oh wow wow I love it
the greatest like over
like let's say Justice League
um in terms of like I'm not saying that
it was the best but like in terms of
like in the Marvel DC Pantheon I'm not
saying please don't come at me and don't
think that I'm saying it was the best
yeah but I loved every second of it
because it balanced for me
the humor the campiness with the
seriousness of DC and James are Jason
Momoa that is the greatest casting just
being in that Subway for the first time
like jumping down oh my God he's showing
his back and he turns around like oh
this this guy don't mess with him yeah
we're bringing that hair in slow-mo well
I could have seen two hours of that I'm
tired of it Extended Cut
um
do you think James has a master plan
like I've heard people say that they
think he's already cast Superman Legacy
like in his brain even though they
haven't announced it like if he's
writing I'm pretty sure you have someone
in your mind like I want this person and
uh or he's a type that let's see who's
the best fit of these characters so I I
really don't know if he's doing one or
two either but I think it's those two
and
uh I don't know who the hell like any
Dreamcast Dreamcast
for Superman It's gotta be
I feel like they can go with like an
unknown yeah yeah I'm okay with that
I feel like he's done that a lot with
like his
uh she was like have one person like be
like the one and then everyone else
surrounding him uh just unknowns but
Superman oh that's a tough one it's
tough yeah someone that represents like
the uh the uh the good and all that the
American way of just being Superman
um in a world that's you know the
synopsis after everyone's cynical
who's who's gonna do in that yeah I
don't know people have said you know
gone down the gauntlet of people because
he likes to work with the same people
and bring them over from other projects
and there was the British is actually a
British actor which I don't know if
people would be upset if they cast a
British actor but I mean look at Tom
Holland
um and I forget his name and I wish I
could remember it but I was I looked at
him and I was like
I immediate I just saw his head shot and
I think he was in Peacemaker I think he
had a small role in Peacemaker and I was
like which one was he I I'll have to
look up his name it'll take me too long
which character was it in Peacemaker I
forget like was he so bad with names was
he the sidekick
um the one that was helping Peacemaker
um
but I think I might know who you're
talking about because there is that yeah
I forgot his name too but he's kind of
he reminds me of Kick Ass uh yeah yeah
yeah he's like an Aaron Taylor Johnson
he looks edgy but he also looks handsome
but he looks like he could have that
handsome like like ability that Superman
has to like have oh yeah because he can
play like an in that show but
still have those likable qualities yes
so imagine going full on Superman I
think yeah he could probably pull it off
yeah so that's sad sorry everybody yeah
that guy
um
I can't I can't look it I can't find it
right now maybe I can find it after we
wrap and they can insert a photo yeah
um anyway
um so overall I mean we liked this movie
no yeah yeah I think the more I'm
talking about it like yeah I really
enjoy this movie yeah I think it's it's
like leave your baggage at the door and
then have a good time oh yeah or you can
bring baggage but bring popcorn in put
it in the baggage in the baggage and
just eat it like this yeah it was a
great time I would have given a fresh
tomato on the audience side on this one
um all right well thank you so much for
joining as we wrap up let everybody know
where they can find you yeah you can
find me at nerdreactor uh
nerdreactor.com social media nerd
reactor saw there and uh thanks for
having me Nikki it was a really fun chat
yeah no same here we get to talk about
just the stuff we like enjoy we're glass
half full people we love these yes
come out as critics all right well thank
you everybody for watching this episode
of the after show and don't forget to
join us on the next one and we will see
you then bye see ya
foreign